how old are you i'm 28. i think 28's a  tricky number because people get  confused because your post college era  30's look at you in the face yeah that's  that's my biggest problem i've been  having lately and that's i've been  watching a lot of you and all kinds of  other stuff and it's helped me kind of  come out and realize you know my time is  is when i ever find it i got my own  clock bro honestly no joke i feel like  you're closer to 2.8 years old than the  way you think about 28 like you've got  16 years of execution in front of you  because i'm telling you that looking at  30 like wait a minute 30's here  shouldn't i quote unquote have my life  together and then at 28 you got 5 to 50  percent of your friends that you went to  high school or college with that are  like you know getting married getting  somewhere in their life  don't let anybody else's clock you know  dictate your game